the price of any financial asset
including bitcoin is also made
determined by supply and demand now
bitcoin is very very unique for one
reason it has a finite supply we know
that there will only ever be 21 million
bitcoin and so when you know exactly
what the total supply is and you also
know that the incoming daily supply is
programmatic about 900 bitcoin a day
right now that means that you don't have
to actually model out what the supply of
the asset will be this is very different
than let's say a public stock where
maybe the company will actually conduct
share buybacks or they may issue more
shares at some point in the future but
with bitcoin there is no need to model
out the supply side of the supply demand
equation that means that you can turn
all of your focus to the demand side and
that demand side ends up helping to
determine what the future price of the
asset will be now of course the supply
is fixed it's finite and it's known but
one of the components that ends up being
a really big driver of the price of
bitcoin is the idea of the bitcoin
having and now the bitcoin having in the
past has drawn massive increases in the
price of bitcoin it's a supply shock it
takes the number of bitcoin that come
into the circulating supply every day
and it cuts it in half before may of
2020 there was 1800 bitcoin a day coming
into the market today there's only 900
bitcoin a day coming into the market and
that is because the bitcoin have it now
these havings occur every 210 000 blocks
or so and of course that's about four
years in terms of the actual time it
takes between havings now the bitcoin
having that happened in may of 2020
before we get to the next one we just
crossed over halfway it's a pretty big
deal that means we're 50 of the way to
the next havoc that fifty percent
progress means that over the next two
years or so we'll walk right into the
next having will be another supply shock
and if history is a guide it likely will
lead to another drastic increase in
bitcoin's price anytime you have a fixed
asset and you get these supply shocks to
the daily incoming supply as long as
demand remains the same or persistently
grows at some known rate that means that
price increases and so as more and more
people come into the market more and
more people will start to understand the
supply demand economics and they will
start to realize that those havings are
never priced in but of course
history does not necessarily serve as a
guide for the future 100 of the time it
may rhyme but it may not absolutely be
replicated perfectly and so you need to
do your own research you need to
understand supply and demand you need to
understand how the bitcoin having works
and then you need to look at things
probabilistically what is the
probability that the bitcoin having in
the future will have an impact i think
it's quite high but there's no guarantee
and so ultimately we're 50 of the way to
the next bitcoin having it'll be another
big milestone but it remains yet to be
seen what exactly will the impact be how
big of an impact on price will it have i
don't know but we're gonna find out in
two years and i can't wait hey you did
you like this video great we make five
of them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time